[MUSIC]
I graduated college feeling
like a total boss lady.
Club leadership, student government, and
let's not forget, one of those fancy
management consulting jobs.
>> [LAUGH]
>> You know them.
[LAUGH] I walked across that stage at
graduation feeling ready to take on
the world.
Within a year though,
that confidence had disappeared.
I watched as each one of my peers
got staffed on cool new projects,
while I sat unstaffed.
After each project interview that resulted
in no project offer, I asked myself,
what's wrong with me?
Why don't they want you?
When I eventually did get staffed,
my manager was cold and critical.
I remember my heart beating as I
walked to his desk to ask a question,
making myself small and unobtrusive.
This timidity followed me
to my second project, but
this one had a lot more
client interaction.
And all of a sudden my feedback
read lacks executive presence.
I internalize this feedback, but without
a mentor to show me how it was done,
or somebody giving me guidance
on how to actually change.
All I did was keep fixating on
the fact that I was inadequate.
I didn't feel ready to take on my job,
much less the world anymore,
my confidence was gone.
That intrinsic,
untouchable belief in myself that I had
started my career with had vanished.
Replaced by fear that I wasn't enough,
doubt that I had a future
in the business world.
And jealousy of everyone around me who
seemed to fit in and have it figured out.
My confidence stayed low,
even as my performance improved enough to
get me here, to the GSB,
with all of you incredible people.
During my MBA one year I stumbled across
some research that changed my own
perspective on my experiences.
It turns out what I had gone through,
starting my career with
relatively high confidence.
And then losing it with time,
that's actually startlingly normal.
Women enter the workforce with confidence
roughly equal to that of their male peers.
With time men's confidence
remains steady but
the number of women who believe they have
what it takes to succeed is cut in half.
It's something called
the confidence cliff.
This phenomenon in which women actually
lose confidence once they've started work.
There's a lot of potential explanations.
Everything from a lack of female role
models and mentors in the workplace.
Lessons taught to young girls about
what it means to be a good girl.
The transition from an educational
experience that's relatively
straight forward.
So work environment that's politically
fraught and which like favors like.
All these factors and
more come together to trip women up
until they have fallen off the cliff.
And look, this isn't just something
happening out there to faceless,
nameless people.
It happens here too.
In fact, when I surveyed
the women in our community,
almost 90% said that they had experienced
a moderate or big decline in confidence.
90%.
Okay, this sucks.
>> [LAUGH]
>> We know that confidence is critical for
success.
Without it, women are less ambitious,
less impactful and
less likely to get that next promotion.
But here's the thing,
when women lose, we all lose.
Our organizations miss out on the talent
of half of our their talent pool,
and our leadership becomes less diverse.
With worse outcomes as a result.
But beyond the organizational impacts and
the professional impact,
it also just feels really shitty.
I hate the feeling of doubting myself.
I hate that in addition to doing my job,
I'm also fighting this
battle with confidence.
But more than anything,
I hate the thought of each new generation
of women falling off the same cliff that
we've been falling off for generations.
This has to stop.
For the class at 2018, 2019,
2020, 2021, 2022 and beyond.
For them I'm standing up here today.
And I invite you to stand with me.
Look, right here in this room we have
the future business leaders of the world.
And an awful lot of people who are going
to be managing teams in the next
few years.
When surveyed,
every single one of the women said that
having a supportive manager or mentor.
Would have had a significant
impact on her confidence of those,
half said that it would
even be game changing.
You have the ability to be game changing
for the young woman on your team.
Don't be like my first manager,
who didn't even see that I was falling off
the confidence cliff right in front him.
Get to know that young woman on your team.
Take her out to coffee.
Mentor her or
introduce her to someone who can.
Realize that your sponsorship will be game
changing not just for others see her but
for how she sees herself And
look, all of your energy, effort and time
on this will pay back to you ten fold.
Not only will you get a more
effective member of your team,
but her loyalty to you will propel
you through the organization.
I know that all of you are wonderful and
you're going to go out there and
be incredible leaders who fight the
confidence cliff along with the women on
your teams.
But we've also gotta start
talking to the women themselves.
Look, this is the group of
people who are so powerful, so
confident when they start their careers.
We've gotta give them the tools and
insight they need to keep that confidence.
So for all the women in this
room who might be trying to
overcome the confidence cliff.
And even for
the 21-year-olds on the other side of that
camera still feeling on top of the world.
And about to start your first
big job in a few months.
You are powerful.
You can take on the world.
If I could give any advice
to my 21-year-old self
as I walked across that
stage at graduation.
This is what I would say.
First, find your mentor, and
get advice on how to guide your particular
manager to be a better ally for you.
Second, don't fall into that same
critical thinking that I had
during the first few years of my career.
Instead see feedback as a opportunity for
growth.
I know, I know, feedback's a gift right?
>> [LAUGH]
>> [LAUGH] But really though,
now I realize that it was my fixed
mindset that meant that I internalized
the feedback I was given as
an condonation of my potential.
And that's a blow to my confidence.
Instead, practice growth mindset,
which is all about
embracing your ability, and
even your imperative, to evolve.
And if that growth takes a while,
go easy on yourself
And last, get your awareness up.
For me, just knowing the confidence cliff
was a thing made me, A, less guilty for
experiencing it, but B,
more motivated to rebuild my confidence.
I didn't want to be just another
stat about gender inequality.
For you I hope knowing about the cliff
makes you more proactive and
fighting it, but
also let's you know you're not alone.
We're all fighting this together on
behalf of all the generations of
women that we will bring up behind us.
So overcome the confidence cliff and
go forward into the world.
I believe in you,
now keep believing in yourself,
thank you.
>> [APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC]